this dude
this this six foot five guy i just
remember him just kicking in the side
door with his foot he just like
collapsed
here's the funniest part too this is the
part that i [ __ ] forgot i didn't do
this but the main dude that tried to uh
come in with this crew and crash the
party they knocked it everybody somebody
knocked this dude out and then people
just started pissing on him
oh thought he was on the floor they
started pissing on his head
what the heck yeah
i forgot about that part did the guy
knock out he was knocked the [ __ ] out in
go ahead
genius brain
[Applause]
hello everybody so my name
number one it's a podcaster host in all
of the united states of america
everybody else die preach
okay that's the end
i quit okay well
hello everybody hello salutations it is
a brand new year
of genius brain as of right now we are
going once a week sundays at 12 p.m oh
and we're back to podcasting oh no
people are gonna be so sad
yeah you know it was kind of a hard move
but um i mean who knows we might get two
again depending on this deal that
happens but the the hard part about it
is like
you know doing podcasts
what's it what past three and a half
years
twice a week and then still trying to do
other projects and businesses it's just
been so hard like it's hard to like
split up my time
properly so you kind of just become
shitty at everything
and there's more things i want to do
with this podcast if i do it once a week
i can make that individual podcast a lot
better
like a lot of people don't understand
that there is no producer i have no crew
you're one man i'm literally a one-man
band right now
and um
part of it was because it started that
way because of pandemic because pandemic
i couldn't see anybody yeah like i
didn't want like three or four people in
a room with me and now that the omicron
variant is out
everybody's getting that [ __ ] i
literally can count past my ten fingers
how many people caught the omicron
variant how are they feeling with the
symptom everybody the worst that i've
heard so far is a fever in the first day
and then it went away oh so this variant
seemingly i am no scientist but it seems
like it's a it's not as severe as the
variant that i got the coven 19 variant
that one wrecked my ass
yeah you lost your taste bud lost my
taste lost um
my smell i had brain fog i had lower
back pain joint pain a fever for three
days it was it was pretty [ __ ]
terrible so was it hard to breathe
no i was breathing perfectly fine i
didn't really have a stuffy nose or
anything but the um the brain fog was
messing me up the most like not being
able to
think was so [ __ ] hard especially
because when you're a podcaster you have
to be really quick on your feet and i i
was having so much [ __ ] trouble how
long did that last brain fog lasted like
four or five months for me it was a long
time oh wow it was a long long time and
i remember it just felt like i was in a
haze every day and i started taking um
like a bunch of different supplements to
see i don't know it could have just been
time that it went away sure but i had i
had absolutely no idea
so now that you're doing only once a
week podcast what can the community look
forward to in 2022 well it's not
project-based it's more personal based
stuff like one of the things that i
really have to get done this year
because i haven't i never actually i
mean i know for a lot of people who have
been watching um
i've so at the peak and i think i
actually weighed more than this before
but i i
i used to have this thing called
myfitnesspal right and myfitnesspal uh
before my account for some reason i had
this old account uh when i started doing
something called funny fat fit
where uh it logged in my original weight
to like how big i got for some reason i
can't access that account anymore i
tried getting into it logging in
but all that information is gone
but i remember in that account it said
the highest i was was like 280.
but
that wasn't the fattest that i got
because i actually gained weight past
that
so um in that account i think i was
probably close to like maybe even closer
to 290 pounds but i had no idea right
like i didn't know this was happening
well in that span of time i wanted to
lose
uh x amount of weight and i exceeded it
i think when i was losing weight i only
wanted to lose like 30 pounds and then
from the 30 pounds for almost like
whatever 280 290 i was like 250.
it's like cool and then from 250 when i
went down to like 220 i was like okay
that was cool then i went to 200. yeah
200 was like where i felt the most fit
um i think anything past that is
possible but
i was so active i was kickboxing all the
time yeah you were that's when you met
nick right
yeah so when i met nick i already lost
like 30 pounds
so when you were with nick you were
still on the bigger side but you had as
big yeah you weren't as big i lost 30
pounds so i was still 250 pounds so
that's 30 pounds heavier than i am now
what you're right now i'm 220.
is it okay 220. yeah so over pandemic i
gained
um
20 pounds
probably more close to 15 because like
205. so what are you do you have like a
goal weight i want to get down to 195.
really that is the ultimate goal weight
for the year
for the year so for the whole year so
2022 of 2022. like i need to get this
thing done like because i haven't ticked
it off the box yet
so it needs to be checked so once you
hit 195 though like what happens after
that i don't know just maintain i could
float from 195 to like 210 and i think
i'll be fine
um 220 is a little heavier for me and so
it's not really like a physical look
thing it's just
my joints hurt like everything when you
gain weight if if you guys don't know
this for anybody who's been who's been
big their whole life right i think a lot
of the times we do things that we
we like to rationalize our weight
because it makes us feel better right so
when you're uncomfortable all the time
and you live in discomfort that becomes
your baseline of how you feel
when you step away from that and you
start losing weight you make healthier
life choices you sleep better you do all
the stuff when that becomes your norm
try gaining that weight back and see how
shitty you feel
like you you feel everything that's
wrong with you so when i was like in
quarantine and i lost my taste the
craziest thing that i recognized was
that
it's insane how
intuitive your body is
because i didn't have taste
i could feel how different foods were
affecting me
so because when food tastes so good
whatever that receptor is whatever the
endorphin that rush you get from eating
good food isn't there anymore and you
don't have taste you're only left with
how the food makes you feel
so even though i lost my taste everybody
bought me snacks you know the distance
they left it at the door so i could eat
it or whatever and i was like you know
what i just want to eat these cookies
because it's a familiar texture and
maybe i might be able to taste something
but i would eat those cookies and i
would feel like [ __ ]
but if i ate celery
salad these juices and because i
couldn't taste them either way i felt
better eating that stuff so when that
that endorphin rush you get from eating
good food isn't there you're only left
with how the food makes you feel whoa
remembering when i got out of quarantine
i lost like 10 pounds like i was i was
my skin looked great too that was the
crazy thing
when i got out of quarantine my skin was
so clear why was that i think it's just
because the food i was eating i was
drinking a [ __ ] ton of water i was
eating uh yogurt uh vegetables fruits
lean proteins
and a lot of soup and then when i came
out my skin was k-pop status i was
i was bts btsing my skin
is that why you posted the oppa on your
photo
because my skin was never going to be
like that ever again oh my gosh yeah but
it's it's pretty damn insane you went to
canada recently how was that oh my god i
love that thank you chad so much for
making me have an amazing trip can i
just say how much of a baby this girl is
i'm such a so before she was about to
leave to canada right and you know i did
warn her about a lot of these travel
restrictions because canada is super
strict about traveling yeah this girl
she would find out that she might not be
able to go because you know borders were
closing up they became really strict
because of coven and people in canada
take kobe very very seriously i get a
phone call you know what she says she
goes i'm over here i'm going to be stuck
in this prison for the rest of my life
this house that we have in a very very
affluent area in los angeles she got she
called it a [ __ ] prison it was okay i
didn't call the house a present i called
my room a prison
oh your room only be are you going to
insert a video clip of what your room
looks like no i love my room my room is
great but when you have to work all day
and cannot get out because of work
it's really hard to appreciate what you
have right so that is why
i have to it's not the look of it it's
the physical
presence of it yeah but you could walk
out of your room and go right outside
exactly which is why i have about 800
steps a day
because that's what i do i'm like i need
some vitamin c so i'll go out do some
laundry get some vitamin d you know what
we call this in korean
like when they just they just everything
is so hyper exaggerated and well that's
that that's the exact reason why i had
to leave because i didn't have this like
mental
break
just like
refresh myself and i really needed that
and that's why i was even willing to go
to toronto
where it said that it was gonna be
raining snowing like things were closing
down and i was like effed i'm gonna take
my chance because i'm about to go crazy
so i did and i'm so glad i did because i
feel so rejuvenated by it um jen and my
friend who i met in taiwan through
dragon boat she was there and she like
totally took care of me it was the great
hospitality um i got to try three
different coffee shops every day walking
about 20 to 30 k steps
and it was like a ghost town there she
was something and that was the best part
is that
it was almost
very empty when jenna and i were working
around she'd be like we never come here
because it's so crowded but there's like
maybe 20 people at most it was so quiet
which i also very loved
yes about 90 of the stores were closed
because
christmas eve christmas day and then day
after christmas is boxing day
the hell is that uh it's where
i don't know it's like their
sale day i i guess okay but christmas
day everything's closed uh boxing day it
was a little bit more packed like the
malls were packed they had lines
everywhere but we didn't want to go
indoors so it was all outdoors but a lot
of the times even after christmas day
and during the week between christmas
and new year's a lot of stores close
because they want to have a holiday um
but that said we weren't in downtown
toronto so we had a lot of access to
like other places so
my goal i told her i was like i just
need to walk
and have some coffee and maybe a little
bit of bread or something that's all i
need and it was fabulous so you just
wanted prison food
i just need bread and water and i'll be
fine okay i needed some fruit to i told
her i was like we need to go to some
veggie restaurant so we went to a place
called
fresh
which is so freaking good it was a like
a vegan place i never trust what her
idea of what hella good is dude every
time she talks about food that's hella
good it's always whatever well you and i
have different palettes she and i really
enjoyed fresh restaurants actually we
have very similar palette and then have
you tried the sandwich called
pee something oh a pea sandwich that
sounds delicious
no it's it's um canadian turkey sandwich
it's called pee
something sandwich i forgot damn it but
it's at st lawrence market
um they came out on tv show
but basically it's canadian turkey
they've had it since like eighteen
hundred and it's been how is that
canadian turkey canadian bacon sorry
canadian bacon
canadian
the [ __ ] is it canadian turkey
bacon gobble gobble eh piemonte no what
the [ __ ] is called but the thing is it
tastes like kind of like turkey and
hammish so you would think so basically
like a smoked turkey
it's not smoke though
it's not smoked i'm very disinterested
in the sandwich but it's so good i
thought it was going to be like greasy
and like you know too much flavor but it
happened to be like the perfect flavor
and seasoning
this sandwich doesn't sound that good to
be honest with you you might not like it
because it probably i don't know you
might not have any flavor
it has enough flavor she she once fed me
so we're here she bought these like
multi-grain like quinoa bowls and i saw
her munching on this [ __ ] like it was
hella delicious she was like oh this is
so good and she spoons it in my mouth it
was [ __ ] disgusting i was okay it was
sour really hungry cold mush it was not
good but this one was really good even
came out on tv that's how we found out
about it well just because things come
out of tv doesn't mean it's good it's
true that's why i was like i'm not sure
but when i had it i was like
so good anyway so i had that i had like
so many different coffees it was so
delicious
what else did i have uh and also her
friends treated me out oh apparently
canada in toronto has the best dim sum
because uh those chefs who were in hong
kong apparently flew over to toronto and
so they're known for like to have like
the most delicious dim sum so i've never
really had dim sum at a place where i'm
like whoa this is the best ever i know
that like usually when they're good
they're all good yeah yeah because
they're serving babies definitely good
like i'm i don't eat them some that
often so i wouldn't know like exactly
what's defined good but this was really
delicious
so yeah you just basically did the same
[ __ ] you could have done here she went
to go he did some she had coffee
it's the same food i would have here but
the difference is that i was walking 30k
i cannot do that here yes you can you
choose not to no it's a different
ambience see i told oh my god i told
jedi how david wouldn't understand this
because
because like when you're walking when
there's a lot of things to see like
you're walking your walk becomes so much
more fun but then if there's nothing but
like just cars passing by there's
nothing fun to look at the walk seems
like infinity
there's plenty of places like that here
you just don't go out you that's the
funny thing about it take me there
here's the fight here's the funny thing
about people who live in l.a like people
who live in this city they tend to get
sometimes they get jaded about things
when they never walk outside the front
of their door like you've it's it's not
just you it's just me
this it's just so crazy out here like
what do you mean i walk every day
i've taken you to yeah you walk in
places well this podcast is brought to
you by luma labs so you've heard of
micro dosing have you but if you haven't
there's info all over the internet well
microdose gummies have micro doses of
thc and they just released six flavors
of higher thc gummies based on sativa
indica and hybrid strains and guess what
because it's hemp derived thc they're
available nationwide listen you deal
with sleep problems or anxiety this just
might be the thang thang for you you're
gonna get a dope mood lift without
getting the thc high which i do not like
there's a reason micro dosing is getting
so popular for health and wellness if
you want to learn more about micro
dosing thc just do a quick search online
or go to
microdosegummies.com and get them
delivered to your door for free shipping
and 30
off your first order use codebrain links
can be found in the show description but
again that's
microdosegummies.com and code brain
granted that one walking spot with
khalif that place is really cool
but like you could just you have you can
walk anywhere and be fine
not anywhere like i'm i'm not going to
be walking around k-town little town oh
no i mean like like i find places with
good scenery yes yeah and usually
they're like nature scenery and that's
great
i i think i'm more i'm so used to
walking around like in you know like in
tokyo like walking and seeing all the
different buildings in taiwan like same
thing and it was the exact same
environment in toronto it just happened
to be downtown toronto that's why and
it's just so fun looking around
different like architecture and like
designs and
it's just it was just fascinating
i enjoyed it so i look i'm glad you had
a great vacation yes
i am so rejuvenated and can i say at
least the canadians whom i met
they're so freaking nice
see that's the funny thing too everybody
in la does this and i don't understand
what the [ __ ] people don't generalize
the l.a no no everybody does this los
angeles every time people leave because
i'm not from los angeles by the way i'm
sacramento all the way 9-1-6 tell me
what's good cut but yeah right so i'm
not from los angeles right
but people from who like either they
lived here or they lived here for an
extended period of time they go
somewhere else and they go oh people are
so much nicer but in my mind i'm like
where the [ __ ] do you go
like who's sacramento
like who the [ __ ] are you talking to the
neighborhood we're the nicest people
ever yeah we walk by good morning hi the
the guy armin the old man he always
greets me all the time i don't know who
armin is see because you don't go out
and so these people they say hi oh you
mean here yeah they say hi they say good
morning they're super sweet they wave so
the it's like perspective it's like we
choose not to see because you're also
out and about and you're exploring if
you're not doing the same here this is a
false comparison people are also very
nice in the city it just depends on
where you're from i'm not saying they're
mean
i didn't say that i didn't say that
they're mean it's just the canadians who
whom i met are very nice and i think
they're also very nice here too and like
i said this is from somebody who's not
from the city like i think people are
very nice i'm pretty sure if you go to a
shitty place in canada there's going to
be so yeah i'm sure rude ass people okay
let's be clear i didn't say people are
rude here i did not say that oh i'm not
saying but i'm saying but it sounds like
everybody does that comparison thing
it's like i think we we don't judge
where we're at where we're at in the
correct lens because the weird thing is
is when people come to los angeles they
explore this place because it's new if
somebody who lives or explored los
angeles as if it was new and they tried
new things it would be just as fun i'm
sure there's a reason why everybody
comes to the city because there's always
something to do here
right yeah so it's like it's it's like
if you could you probably had the time
of your life here too if you would
explore the city i mean look look i
don't know what's going on i don't know
what's going on here but i didn't say
that i don't like it here i didn't say
that either
i here's the thing i came back home and
i said man do i love my home
so
because you love it i do like it here i
just like i said i needed a need a break
i'm telling you from york's from my
experience with you you you have you
don't explore this city at all well
maybe it's because this is your city
yeah you know what i mean because i'm
not from here
so when i see stuff here in los angeles
there's always something to do there's
always something fun going on there's
other places there's new restaurants
there's just so many things yeah when
you're here though your energy here
versus when you go somewhere else is two
different things of course because there
is just pure fun like it's vacation i
don't need to worry about anything i
don't need to do errands to be an adult
i could just
live
you could do that here though you choose
not like this is this is just me being
stripped i'm i've been with her now for
seven years you're so weird i don't
understand why you're like
putting rain over me i'm just like i had
a good time i'm not saying you shouldn't
have a good time i'm saying that oh you
could also do that stuff here yeah i'm
sure i can yeah i never say i cannot i
just needed a break from my house just
like how you go out for a walk like
during pandemic you went out for like
four months four hours i think this just
stems from the conversation of you
calling this place a prison yeah because
i i find that offensive why do you find
that offensive this is a nice place it
is a nice one it's just like this if you
eat your favorite food every day
you won't appreciate as much as you have
it once in a while a better comparison
is this your favorite food is in your
face every day but you have a phone that
has postmates with different foods and
you choose not to use it that's how i
view it huh
my eyes twitch
your room so your room
is your favorite food okay right
but they're right outside your room
there's
pizza pasta everything else you just
don't look at it and you're just focused
on the fact that you have to eat this
every day even though it's really good
it's what i'm saying that's my
comparison right i'm not saying it's
just you i just hear so many people do
that for some reason like people in the
city like they go oh i need to get away
from the city it's like you know like
downtown los angeles like this big
there's like there's so many other parts
of the city to explore yeah i think it's
just that yeah i think that's the part
is that if you want to explore
i don't like driving
so that involves driving i want to just
walk i could walk here but there's not
much to explore when you're walking or
just exploring to see different houses
different mountains different front yard
but not really like architecture-wise
it's just not as like different and
vibrant you know i mean i could drive
down to like maybe k-town or art
district but there's driving involved
and it's a very
intense driving anybody who knows who
drive through downtown l.a it is insane
but yes
that said i needed a little break so i
could come back and appreciate things
more which i do like for example i
wonder if you could just kind of do that
thing in your head where you click and
you try to explore los angeles as if you
don't live here
i could probably because right now
everything you talk about about the city
when you do things everything's a chore
and i know this
because it's going outside it's a tour
like going outside is a chore like even
like you know what i'm saying like
you've you've lost that that that thing
about you where you can
your explorative behavior in this city
has disappeared now
and you haven't experienced a lot what
this city just has to offer right
because there's a reason why people come
here it's because it's fun there's a
reason why people literally travel
across
this country to come here and have fun
so it's like when i hear people who live
here they're jaded about stuff when they
haven't even heard or have been to the
things that's why like when people come
here and they they kind of show me
around the city because they have this
like itinerary list that i never even
knew about yeah it's like when you're at
the beach living at the beach
or close to the beach you rarely go to
the beach because it's just right there
not me dude if i'm next to the beach
your boy going to the beach baby
yeah so when i used to live
in culver city near the beach i would
always take out a takeout take my bike
to marina del rey and bike around there
because i loved the scenery of it
so i do explore and then i will kind of
just get lost in my way but like there's
just so much to explore over there that
it was fine i think it's just our
certain area here which i still love
well yeah i think it's because we're
also in a very like suburb area so our
suburban area doesn't really have like
too many close coffee shops or whatever
if we want to go to a nice coffee shop
we have to kind of go a little bit of
ways yeah so it's it's not as accessible
as certain other parts because when you
were in culver city everything was just
a bike right away it was so fun and it
was not only by
a way but there were just so much to
explore
there's just a different thing about it
yeah
i don't know
but that all said i'm really glad to be
back because when i was on that vacation
which was so much fun part of me like
there i had a thought for a second be
like oh i feel good i can't wait to go
back home and work now and i was like
whoa
i'm rejuvenated rejuvenated not so happy
you had such a different life growing so
every time i go so i went back to
sacramento for christmas right and the
weird thing about going back to
sacramento for christmas is like
they're so i get to kick it with a lot
of my old old friends from back in the
day right and you know i've had i lived
a very duplicitous life meaning that i
hung out with so many different people
depending on what's on what station no
that's not being too fast i'm just
kidding it's you you're depending on
what stage of your life right so it's
like when i was super into anime i was
hanging out with these anime kids right
and then when i wanted to do like stupid
[ __ ] i was hanging out with a bunch of
other different people but there are
parts of like these stories that i
remember that other people remember
differently because we kind of create
our own narrative in our hair and so i
was telling her this where
and i've told this story too but
years ago
um there was this there's a spot so
sacramento is originally a huge farm
town right
a lot of agriculture there even in my
high school we had an agriculture
program every
every semester or so they would bring in
like farm animals for us to pet and
touch um but
so there would be like homes like on the
strip in this area in sacramento where
it's just all fields and there's a lot
of like new development homes there now
but before it would just be somebody in
this huge area with just like a shack
well those shacks
people would either throw raves they
would throw huge party house parties or
whatever right
um and there was a lady that we used to
kick it with she was a lot older i don't
know
exactly who she is or who she was
connected to if that was somebody's aunt
or whatever but she always allowed us to
throw parties at her house she was super
chill she also used to grow a lot of
weed so and this is when it was illegal
so she used to grow a sativa like out
there and then you know she would allow
whoever wanted to smoke some [ __ ] here
and there and then buy buy offer and
stuff like that
well
i met up with a buddy of mine and then
we started reminiscing about these dumb
stories and i was telling him the story
about the time where we were throwing a
party there and there was a group of
dudes that try to crash this party
so for us if we don't know you you're
not allowed to come to the party it's
just safer that way
right and there was people over there
who were you know quote unquote a little
dangerous but they were all chill we
were all friends that kind of grew up
together
when i told this story how i remembered
it was
he was out in the front these dudes were
basically causing trouble saying that
they were to come to the party and then
you know my buddy comes up to me he goes
hey shit's going down and i'm like [ __ ]
you know i don't
want to do this but if your friend asks
you to back you up you're going to back
them up a huge brawl breaks out we just
start [ __ ] throwing down it was like
everybody they didn't know that
everybody in this house party everybody
knew each other
so it wasn't like three or four people
are gonna fight these other four three
or four or five people or whatever it
was the whole house was gonna come out
and [ __ ] these dudes up and that's
exactly what happened it was literally a
huge brawl what i completely forgot and
this is what he told me he goes hey
remember when you [ __ ] started
smashing that dude's car up like it was
a street fighter game
and i paused
and i was like that's right i actually
forgot about that part of the story so
what happened was the main dude that was
mouthing off he got his [ __ ] ass beat
specifically there was a dude i'm not
gonna say his name but he was like a six
foot five samoan dude
huge he looked like a giant and this
dude for some reason
he would just always look for fights he
could he would [ __ ] everybody up this
dude happened to be at the party he was
beating the [ __ ] out of everybody like
tossing people just chucking people and
the guys who came over they all got the
[ __ ] beaten out of them and then
everybody started [ __ ] up their car
the car that they rolled in
and so we started like kicking in the
side door smashing out the side view
neighbors calling 9-1-1 no this is a
farm town there's no neighbors
it's literally a shack in the middle of
a field
there's nobody around and so
literally this dude
this this six foot five guy i just
remember him just kicking in the side
door with his foot he just like
collapsed
here's the funniest part too this is the
part that i [ __ ] forgot i didn't do
this but the main dude that tried to uh
come in with this crew and crash the
party they knocked it everybody somebody
knocked this dude out and then people
just started pissing on him
oh he was on the floor they started
pissing on his head yeah
what the heck yeah
i forgot about that part did the guy
knocked out he was knocked the [ __ ] out
he was on the floor and then people just
started pissing on his head oh gross
see i don't i don't i i was never in
that kind of party i was i think i was
21 at the time like i wasn't i wasn't
super young
can i tell you a story that i as you
were saying this it reminded me a story
that janet told me which i completely
forgot but when we're in taiwan
we went to go see a palm reader he's
like really well-known palm reader guy
and only spoke chinese so janet came
with me or she took me there and to
translate
and he was telling me about my life life
story and he's like very accurate about
the future and he was saying oh in the
next few years like you know coming soon
like you're going to be working in the
entertainment blah blah blah i was like
oh okay which actually did happen
and he said oh soon you'll meet your man
and what i remember is that i'll just
meet my man but then janet when we met
the sir this time she said do you
remember how accurate that guy was i was
like what are you talking about he's
like he said you'll meet a big guy who's
really funny
that's so general though but i said
am i really no because we're asking so
how is this guy i was like is he good
looking blah blah blah and he said well
he's going to be very funny
and so he basically said i was lucky
[ __ ] this guy what's his name
what's this fortune teller's name oh
[ __ ] this full up
is that is he gonna be good looking well
he's funny this is the most offensive
thing we're adding the podcast right now
excuse me i think you're good looking
okay
no but when you weigh 300 pounds the way
he dodged you were very cute the way he
dodged that question is hilarious though
is he is he good-looking
he's funny
no he's straight-up said no
didn't dodge it i was trying to be nice
but if you want to know the accuracy he
said no but well he was wrong i guess
he's not very accurate
he said he's pretty big like tall and he
is going to be a very funny guy like he
will make you laugh
and i
don't recall that part and john said i
recall that because i had to translate
it for you i was like oh
so yeah where's he at but he also said
you were going to get married at 26. 27
which didn't happen yeah it was wrong
and he was wrong about me being ugly
this guy doesn't know [ __ ]
what's his address i'm beating his ass
hey do you care so much if i think that
you're cute
i don't care this guy called me ugly all
right i don't want this [ __ ] fortune
teller oh yeah so what does he look like
oh you know
you a goblin
you know clown
a clown you know he might smell a little
funny
he's from sacramento oh smell funny you
smell great i always smell good i know
you do i always smoke if you smell bad
i'd be like
sorry no i can't i can't smell bad big
people can't smell bad that's the
general rule of thumb i'm glad please
say it out loud out there
i got to catch up on so many people you
know what the sad thing is is is when
you
hear these stories about people that
uh
in my eyes were very promising right
it kind of just goes to show too it's
like you could have all the talent in
the world but if you don't have the
right people around you
and discipline it doesn't [ __ ] matter
some of the most
gifted human beings that i grew up with
right and in high school they had very
magnetic personalities everybody wanted
to be friends with them
super funny very talented very likable
sociable girls liked them everything was
poppin and then i met up with a couple
of friends asked how they're doing all
coked out heroin heroin addicts
the saddest [ __ ] thing and to be
honest with you i got a little a little
emotional because
we all grew up in the same neighborhood
but it's weird how
though we all grew up in the same
neighborhood there's some small little
factors in their life that's very
different from mine that make them go
different ways right so one guy
um was a b-boy
uh just a really funny cool chill dude
was in the wrestling team uh he ended up
actually owning his own um pool business
where he would like he had his own
business at the age of like 25 like we
were super [ __ ] young so when we were
all struggling he was a business owner
killing it finds out his business is
gone he did some other [ __ ] he's like he
got he got hooked on heroin or cocaine i
forgot which i don't even know how the
[ __ ] that happened and you know his
business gone he got rid of everything i
think just just to fuel his habit
another buddy of mine and i always say
this too it's like
i'm probably to me in my personal
opinion one of the least funniest people
in my group
everybody else is 10 times funnier than
i am i was just better at piecing it
together and making stand up out of it
or content because sometimes when you're
a funny person doesn't mean that you're
a very good performer or a great
entertainer right i just you know they
these guys arguably every time i see
them i'm crying laughing because that's
how funny they are sure one of the guys
um
he
we actually started doing stand-up
together around the same time
right this dude
is so [ __ ] funny like i remember uh
he he didn't
he got discouraged doing stand-up
because he had a set that he just
completely busted on and it kind of
wrecked his his like
his ego
his pride a little bit because every
time we're in a group together if we
tell jokes he's always having us in
tears laughing and that's how funny his
jokes are but you know a lot of the
times like funny people forget it's like
stand up comedy is a performance thing
it's in an entertainment you have to
work on this this shit's a [ __ ] uh
it's a skill that you have to work on i
don't think he really understood that so
he tried to tell these jokes on stage
where
it was funny to us because we knew who
he was we knew who his wife was at the
time and there's background story to him
well when you tell this joke or this
funny little setup you have to tell this
joke to people who don't know who the
[ __ ] you are they don't have the
background they don't know that you're a
funny person you have to prove how funny
you are and he didn't really think about
that because he was doing the set it was
it's a set that he tried to work on
because it was joke that he told us
about how his the first time he tried
anal with his wife and it was literally
the funniest [ __ ] story i've ever
heard in my life but he didn't know how
to translate it on stage
um but having said that this guy was
super [ __ ] talented he was just dope
at everything that he did um come to
find out trying to find out where he was
a friend of mine lent him a few you know
a few thousand dollars to help you know
get his get him back on his feet
obviously never paid it back uh was
hooked up on like heroin
he got how do people get hooked up on
heroin because that's like so much money
i don't know like i was heroin like
opioid right so you know um
i mean maybe they were really depressed
people people love that feeling i i
personally hate it so you tried it no
like when when i was in the hospital
with you you saw me on the iv dream
where i had an opioid inside me oh you
had me all space i [ __ ] hated that
feeling i hate it i hate it with
everything that i have that's why i
don't like being high either because i
don't like that feeling of just being
loose they're like well just let
yourself go i actually hate that feeling
you're so in control
david loosen up i could be loosened up
but i don't need drugs to do that though
i could just i could just be in the
ocean and float for four hours and not
think of anything true would i walk i
can't do that like yesterday i walked
six
five miles my mind just went blank and i
just kept walking in circles so i don't
need stuff to be disconnected and then
kind of relax i can do that on my own
the problem is is that i wanna do it
when i choose to and i wanna snap out of
it when i wanna snap out of it sure when
i'm high it doesn't have it's just i'm
oh my god you know i just gotta
please stop now
you know i don't like it but it's sad
like i went back and
finding out these dudes just didn't turn
out the way that i expected them to was
or just like any of us thought yeah and
it kind of goes to show with the idea of
[Music]
talent doesn't mean [ __ ] without action
and it really depends on the people that
you grew up around so
a lot of the friends who we hung out
with that kind of did better than these
people better in the terms of like our
careers and our life choices right
we
all left
we we still hang out with the same group
when we meet together but everybody kind
of left
one of the guys went to the military
um
gobble became a doctor he moved over to
new york
um i moved to los angeles we all kind of
like
stepped away and we saw something that
was a lot bigger because when you grow
up in a very small town sometimes the
only thing that you can base your
success or your goals on are this just a
small group of people around you and
that's the only perspective that you
have yeah and then some people become
very narrow-minded yeah because of that
and it happens a lot too like it's you
know we call these echo chambers right
like you you just you only say things or
hear things that you want to hear and
everybody else's opinion is really
really [ __ ] dumb right and just
having that conversation constantly is
like we've we've seen it multiple times
right like
i've seen it so often especially like
around certain people that she knows
like i i have trouble being around them
because they are the exact example of
people who ask questions not to know
what the answer is they ask questions
expecting you to say something that they
already believe in and that is one of
the most [ __ ] annoying things
that anybody can do so they'll like i'll
just throw out a random example it'll be
like oh uh what is this couch made out
of right
and then you'll say oh it's 100 leather
and they go i don't think that it's
leather it's like well yeah well you
know i got it from this place this
person made it blah blah blah they're
like well who's the person it's like the
person is from i don't know from this
place and they make the leather
hand-stitched oh when did you meet him
he's like okay what the [ __ ] do you want
now
no it's not leather it's like are you
gonna are you interested in this leather
no are you interested in the couch
are you gonna get a couch soon no then
why are you asking me all these
questions who cares yeah those people
are the hardest people to be around yeah
because like i said they're not they
never ask questions because they're
curious they ask questions because they
already have an answer in their head
that they want you to confirm
so when you go back and have reunion
then
how do you
have
because everyone is different it's so
different that some people you could
still communicate but the others such as
example
you could have only limited conversation
so when you guys come back together how
do you guys still all mingle and
[Music]
keep in touch well i have different
groups though so like there's a certain
group of people that
that don't really get along with this
group and the other person doesn't get
along with this group but because i was
kind of like a little bit everywhere i
kind of get along with everybody
so
um
we don't really cross mingle like that
but these people just because we have
different lifestyle doesn't mean that
they don't have anything to offer in
these conversations right so
what i do is vastly different from what
my other friends do
right but that's kind of the exciting
thing it's very very fun to go ahead and
hear what they're doing and sometimes
too like i don't like it when people go
oh i'm not doing some exciting [ __ ] like
you i didn't ask you what i know what
the [ __ ] i do
all right and in fact i don't even like
talking about the [ __ ] that i do what do
you do
right because i want to know i want to
learn about you know the life that you
lived in the past three years but
sometimes when they hear about my career
they're like oh it's not going to be fun
it's exciting well
that's very subjective you know like
what have you been up to in the last few
years like one of the saddest things
that i ever heard too and i was telling
her this too uh on the phone when i
found out there was a kid that um
i'm not going to say names but literally
it was all over the news
but um you know home invasions were
really big
um
i've told a previous story where
somebody that i knew is actually still
in jail now for
not a friend of mine but somebody that i
knew it's um
my friend's
sibling
[ __ ] invades a home
goes inside tries to rob it
um sexually assaults the girl that was
inside that house
weak gets caught
um
he wasn't very smart
in jail now probably for a very very
long time maybe i he's been in there for
quite a few years already but i think
his term is still like another like 20
years
that's a very very long time and i'm by
the way i'm using the word sexual
assault because you know what the actual
word is so um
there's somebody else that we used to
kick it with back in the day this is not
him but this is this person's sibling
um i remember that sibling
very very sweet
right
super goofy very nice whatever
um
turns out there was an article about um
this guy's sibling uh invaded a home
murdered two brothers
and murdered the father that was in the
house
and
the craziest [ __ ] from a home
invasion and this house was did he have
a gun
yes shot both the brothers to death and
then killed the father too that was in
the house
the craziest [ __ ] thing about that
[ __ ] is that was like literally right
around the corner from my house
like
maybe a two-minute drive
that's how close it was from where i
from where where i live
blows my [ __ ] mind two three minute
drive or whatever it's the most insane
thing i've ever heard in my life and you
look at this kid and i want to figure
out what happened along the way that
made this person that way and by the way
too craziest part about the story is
that the i believe the person that he
killed is actually his friend
did he know that it was his friend i'm
not sure i mean i highly doubt that he
didn't know but if he didn't know and he
just invaded this home and killed him
and and the dude's brother and the
father blows my [ __ ] mind
how do you i don't know it's like how do
you kill someone people don't know like
when i tell these stories about like how
i grew up and where i live it kind of
seems like a farfetched idea right
but once again i found a strong group of
people that helped mold me to be a
better person right and also i had
really great parents as well maybe these
people didn't
and it just
i just know for a fact too i believe in
their life like the parents are very
kind of absent because they're you know
they're also immigrant parents too
they're they're working every day so the
hand and raising these kids are also a
lot more distant than
the regular family that you see
right so it's like when you see the the
the classic seventh heaven family yeah
right mom and dad are there hey kid
what do you want for breakfast oh i want
some cereal fruit loops gotcha
it wasn't like that in my house when i
when i woke up in the morning my mom had
breakfast laid out and they were already
at work
you know
when we came home we had dinner and we
had a meal together but other than that
or i was working at the store with them
so this is like the reality that we have
and you know as much as i fought with my
parents all the time they had a heavy
hand in the way that i was raised and
they also showed me that i was loved a
lot of my friends even even going back
and having conversations with them now
they don't
they
they're not sure
we had a we had this thing too where i
was like hey does your parents ever say
i love you to you because absolutely not
asian uh asian
it's a common thing in asia though yeah
they go no they don't they don't say i
was like because i don't think i've ever
hugged my dad
it's very common yeah
especially if it's a dude yeah cause i
hug my dad i hook my dad i i you know i
still give my mom kisses and i still hug
my mom yeah you do which is not common
i mean asian community where instead of
saying i love you you say did you eat
you want to eat yeah like that's our
language saying i love you like we care
about you but
i mean especially our parents generation
it wasn't part of us so
unfortunately um but some people
fortunately like your family you guys
could you guys do it like i it's hard
for my family to say that it's not
common yeah like we didn't grow up
saying it though but there's something
that definitely flipped in my parents
mind where they they wanted to say i
love you they wanted this good they
wanted to reach out because my mom never
really said i love you too growing up
like it just wasn't but one of the
things that she was very very like um
adamant about was creating a close
relationship like she said too like you
listen you if you didn't weren't gonna
call me every friday i was gonna call
you because no matter what i'm gonna be
a part of your life you have no choice
so
it took a very long time but eventually
i i found the importance of being close
to my mom and developing that
relationship because before it wasn't
like that yeah it was it was very very
weird and awkward she would i would
never call her on fridays and that's the
only thing she would ask when i went to
college she goes the only thing you have
to do is call me on friday
whether it's in the morning or night
just call me and i would never ever do
it
and my mom would be so pissed she would
get so [ __ ] mad i mean as a normal
boy in college yeah by calling your mom
friday is not
something you would like to do that's
it's normal but your mom was persistent
about it and so
now you guys still talk
which is kind of crazy and you guys have
really really close relationship
although your mom personality is someone
who can talk to anyone not feel
uncomfortable and she has a great
personality i always wondered too was
like not all parents were like that
because i remember just talking to my
mom and i asked her
um
like what she was going through during
the time that i was always getting into
fights and she she just said that it was
very stressful she was always scared
that you know something was going to
happen to me
but she also understood i got bullied a
lot
so it was like
you know what do you what do you do here
you know i mean like what what do you
[ __ ] do like i was so troubled i
remember when i was in korea and um
i didn't know
i don't know korean culture i only know
korean culture from a korean-american
perspective i'm an american that's a
korean kid right
so i'm you know i'm definitively korean
american but when i was in korea i
didn't understand
really the hierarchy importance of age
i didn't get it right so when i was in
korea i remember i got in trouble
because we were in a subway and this
dude shoulder bump i'm 14 by the way but
i'm this size
14 and this like older guy he's probably
in college or whatever he's walking he
shoulder bumps me and i [ __ ] turn him
around and i stare at him like the [ __ ]
right and my mom just got so mad she
goes you can't do that i was like why
it's like she's older i don't give a
[ __ ] this guy just pushed me
right she goes it's different here like
he's an older person just let it go i i
couldn't
so i could just imagine the amount of
anxiety my mom had and i remember my
aunt was there and she was telling me in
korean she goes you know if you're my
kid i just [ __ ] kill you
all right
whoa right and then you know me as an
american kid i didn't really take light
to that i just stared at her i was like
you know like i'm not your kid don't
talk to me like that you know my mom was
just so embarrassed yeah because it's
just a cultural difference you know yeah
i remember in korea too watching this
weird site we went to go watch matrix
the first one
i was 14 at the time or so or
or fifth 13 15 i don't know something
like that
i was super young right
13 maybe 13 yeah so
this guy may be your height and another
korean dude my height
and the small guy started punking the
bigger dude
and i couldn't
wrap my head around it
i was like what the [ __ ] is going on and
he was just staring at him like
walking him down right and the bigger
guy was just like kind of cowering
and i didn't realize until later on it
was because he was the young
he's older
and he's a little tongsen so tongsen
never talks back to older hill no matter
the size difference because in my mind i
was looking like you should just beat
his ass
so how would you
would you react differently now if you
went back no
really so if someone bumped into you you
still give them the dirty look probably
really sure but shouldn't you
uh respect the culture if you're in that
culture i will respect it to a certain
extent but i just don't like people
touching me i mean he didn't touch you
it was just you guys bumped into each
other's shoulder right well no he bumped
me pretty [ __ ] hard i think i was a
bigger guy so
but it's just like
it's super disrespectful you know so he
did it on purpose oh for sure he did it
on purpose like it wasn't like
kind and gentle like he kind of just
bumped me really hard but i think for my
mom it's like
don't cause a scene yeah you know in
america it's like the [ __ ] are you doing
don't [ __ ] touch me yeah you could
say that but over here i'm also a 14
year old kid and even if he did it on
purpose my mom was telling me to let it
go yeah i'm an adult now i'm [ __ ] you
do that to me as an adult it's different
really so you would cause a scene in
korea i wouldn't cause a seat in korea
well my korean's a lot better now too so
i would just kind of give them a little
talking to
you know especially if it's not close to
my age
so but you know there's all this like
just growth that's happened since i was
a kid and just kind of looking back and
to see how where people are and where
i'm at now it's so [ __ ] crazy because
these people were the ones that i
thought were going to be
we're going to excel just don't know
where life takes you
i didn't know i was going to be here
what do you mean here just here in here
i didn't know i would be with a dude for
like
seven years what did you expect i don't
honestly i thought i would be just like
living abroad i didn't think i would be
here in l.a
what you've been doing for a living well
in the past before i got to
entertainment i was doing international
business so i was just like traveling to
different countries for different
companies
but
i
it wasn't the traveling it was just like
the business side of it i didn't really
like but
um i always had this fantasy that i'll
be living abroad
so when i was in taiwan i thought i was
going to be sticking i'll be sick i'll
be in taiwan for longer than anticipated
but i had an accident and i had to come
back but it was for a good reason
because
i got to spend my time with my grandma
before she passed away
that said though if it wasn't for that
accident i was planning to stick around
there for longer because i wanted to
like see what else is out there
mm-hmm
but now my job is mostly here and prison
yeah by the way if you think that i
don't see it the right way you should
take me around to places that you think
oh you would appreciate you don't like
walking
you could ask janet about that that is
not true i don't like talking oh you
have literally told me it's i don't
environment the environment is great i
took you to a trail and you're like this
is so
long
so it's subjective obviously because you
have standards i have standards
in my standards your sound is right here
my son is up here princess dude sorry
princess she needs everything say one i
did tell you i'm a kung ju so
princess
oh my god you're welcome
right what's the temperature outside
what what are my shoes like yeah exactly
you need to rough it out i'm from the
screech
i don't know how we got together so full
or opposite
over the screen
we're so different i took her to this
part in sacramento once where there's
like some of my favorites like like
she was like oh my god you hung out here
it was like a dead zone like someone got
murdered there probably somebody it's
pretty bad i'll tell you this so now
that i'm older i i can't hang out there
good i shoot it i get scared i'm like oh
look at these schools i mean when you're
in high school when you're a teenager
nothing you're fearless yeah like i was
fearless to do crazy things well quote
unquote crazy
but now i'm just like nope i like to be
in the safe area with safe people and
just
look around and walk in a very
comfortable environment
oh i'm glad you enjoyed well guys that
wraps up this podcast
um
genius brain every sundays from here on
out 12 p.m you can catch marilyn marial
underscore underscore song
and genius brain every sunday's at 12
p.m i hope you guys had had it lovely
last year because this year is going to
be fantastic we're going to be doing
dope [ __ ] we're probably going to be
reformatting the podcast too i just need
some time
and i need to get a team together but
it's going to happen i'll see you all
next time i love you very much suck my
butt bye